hello fellow pedestrians you know that
feeling when you're at the airport and
you step onto a moving sidewalk you're
still walking but suddenly the world is
floating by so much faster and you have
all this extra effortless speed well
that's the idea behind these they're
called moonwalkers and they basically
put an electric moving sidewalk under
each of your shoes they promise to
increase your walking speed by 250
percent with no additional effort so
questions are they real apparently are
they ridiculous possibly are they safe
are they Tough Enough do they work are
they actually good
so we reached out to shift robotics here
in winter in Pittsburgh and we're going
to check out their r d lab
all right I'm all ready to go to work as
a Moonshiner anyway let's see how this
goes
first things first I need to know how
these things work so I'm going to get a
crash course from the very guy who
dreamed them up okay so I'll help you to
activate them what we should do is lift
up our heel yeah right heel and turn
inside yeah and then put it down and put
that down so see the green LED here yeah
they turn green that means now you're in
shift mode okay yep it's like a it's
like a Dorothy Wizard of Oz yeah to go
back to the lock mode right all you need
to do is lift the same heel that you
just use for shifting for moving into
the shift mode by doing this okay and
put them down oh that's it you unlock
mode again back to the white light let's
get started all right whoa oh my God
oh whoa all right
that's right that's right
this is such a strange feeling I mean it
really feels like I've got a moving
sidewalk under my feet that's sort of
adjusting
to the way I go all right now that I've
got the basics down it's time to put
these babies through some trials first
up the brake test
walking fast is obviously great but if
you can't stop real quickly then that
could be a disaster so we got a tape
measure on the ground we're gonna see if
I can go full speed and get down to a
stop within like five feet let's see how
this goes
oh my God this feels dangerous
oh okay
that was all right I think I actually
get closer than five feet let me try
that again four feet four feet yeah yeah
yeah all right full speed and
I'll take that any day see teeth
unchipped okay these things are pretty
fun but they're not just Heelys for
grown-ups they're powered by brushless
motors and some onboard machine learning
I'd love to get into the nitty-gritty of
how these things actually work so one of
the things that you talk about is an AI
drive train right right sort of learns
from you as you go can you explain a
little bit about how that works this I'm
your sensor inside which basically
detect how your feet move with each
other when they are in operation
actually to moonwalkers communicate with
each other real fast via Bluetooth at
100 times a second okay they kind of
figure out where shoes are in relatively
in space relative to each other to each
other yeah in spatial relationships but
we're also looking at the power looking
at the force coming from the motor as
well so we know exactly how much force
you're pushing off the ground at the
same time so if I have like a very
specific kind of like strut it would
learn my strut right right right right
right obviously whizzing a margin but
yes it will be able to learn most of
people's stride okay cool yeah my strut
is patent-pending
okay so these things are supposed to
work in pretty much everyday conditions
so we're going to try them in a couple
different types of terrain and see how
they navigate a few different obstacles
as well
I really feel like I'm just going to
catch an edge and go flying Straight
Into the Heart of the gnarly stuff
pitted Pittsburgh streets
oh wow oh my God
I have to say I'm shocked that these
little tiny wheels are navigating these
huge cracks I mean you see they almost
half disappear into them and yet it
rolls right over them with a lot of ease
I mean I guess that's redundancy right
you got 10 wheels that's super
impressive that's that's ridiculous
what's the idea of why so many wheels
compared to like a four-wheel roller
skate or rollerblade right right right
right so to be able to go over bumps of
cracks and we need to make the wheel
large enough kind of patented the idea
is that we try to stack the wheel
together so that even though they are
small but simulate much much larger
Radiance of radios all right let's go
for a few more tests so we want to try
to get some slightly more concrete
measurables so I'm going to be racing
myself now this time with my heart rate
monitor watch on I'm gonna go as fast as
I can to the end of the block and back
in these moonwalkers and then I'm going
to try to run at the exact same speed
and see if my heart rate is a lot higher
my wrist heart rate is currently at 95
because I'm trying to not die of
hypothermia so go
[Music]
so I rented it almost the same speed my
heart rate is 147.
hey you can see that
147
so
more or less the same speed definitely a
lot more exertion
this is actually the ninth iteration of
the moonwalkers so we've been going
through at least nine generational major
iteration and countless of minor
situations to arrive where we are today
which was the first one so this one was
de facto really the first one
this is before like AI was integrated
absolutely hit the button your feet
could actually just shoot out absolutely
yeah if you don't release that you can
actually fly I'm just curious where did
this idea come from like like why if we
can really enhance and argument the way
people walk especially in places like
San Francisco LA New York but most of
people commute around on foot or mass
transit right if we can help them to cut
the commuting time by half that's a huge
saver for them pedal assist electric
bikes are kind of like help you go
faster in the bike Lane right with less
effort this idea is sort of like a a
walking assist electric absolutely
electric shoe to help you go faster just
on the sidewalks all right time for one
final test how do these babies hold up
to a real professional speed Walker Dean
is a two times Collegiate National
Champion speedwalker recently turned Pro
Dean how fast you typically speed walk a
mile around six flat these can go seven
miles an hour my math is not strong
right now but I'm pretty sure that means
you're gonna win but let's find out yep
oh my God he's so fast he's so fast
I want him steroid tested all right so
Dean demolished me that time but you
know these things take a little while to
get up to speed so we're going to give
me a little bit of a handicap to to get
going all right ready here I go five
four three
two one all right I'm pretty much up to
speed
concealed Dean already breathing down my
neck oh [ __ ] as fast as I can oh oh
no he's so fast
[Music]
let's hit the highs and lows High these
things actually worked a lot better than
I expected them to and they handled some
really rough rutted out terrain I was
shocked at how well they did felt like I
had super powers a little bit it almost
felt like I was ice skating over land
these actually felt a lot safer than I
expected them to as well they're really
pretty portable even if they ran out of
batteries you could just toss them in a
backpack and I like that they're
universally chargeable with a USBC you
just charge them onto your desk and
you're ready to go home they had pretty
good stopping power and I didn't feel
like they were just going to shoot out
from under me unexpectedly they felt
very intuitive they felt like they were
gonna do what I wanted them to do not
what they wanted to do hopefully nobody
hacks them and turns them into rocket
shoes low there's still a few Comfort
things that need to be worked out these
straps really do dig in a little bit
especially when you're wearing lighter
weight shoes and I feel like they need
to work on spreading out the pressure on
your feet weighing in at 4.2 pounds each
you really do feel it with every step
not so much when you're walking and
gliding but when it's powered off in in
lock mode going upstairs that's a real
significant weight that you've got under
your feet they're also certainly on the
pricey side which makes them a bit of a
luxury item and that's going to
eliminate them for a lot of people but
if you're commuting in them daily I
could see it actually being worth it
overall I have to say I really like
these things a lot more than I expected
to they were just super fun and yeah if
I had a pair I would definitely Rock
them around town at least some of the
time with all that being said I got a
little moonwalking to do
foreign
[Music]